it is great to be joined today by
Michelle gelfand who's a distinguished
University professor at the University
of Maryland one of the leading world's
experts on cultural differences her new
book is called rule makers rule breakers
how tight and loose cultures wire our
world Michelle so great to talk to you
today really appreciate you joining me
great to be here so to begin with I want
to talk a little bit about sort of the
divisions that often surface in Western
society and then maybe we can get into
whether some of those divisions are real
fake exaggerated who benefits from those
divisions so I mean first and foremost
when we talk about differences within
cultures what are like the top level
categories that we usually are thinking
about so it's a great question because
often we're focused on what I'd call
kind of superficial distinctions like
red versus blue state or rich versus
poor urban versus rural and these are
important distinctions but they don't
get at what I think is a deeper cultural
code that is more typically dividing us
in this country and that's playing into
a lot of electoral dynamics and what are
those other layers that we might analyze
in terms of how these divisions are
forming and kind of being reinforced so
I'm I'm in studying cultures for about
two and a half decades I'm a
cross-cultural psychologist and been
studying ancient cultures like Athens
and Sparta up to modern nations like
Japan and the Netherlands to the US and
even US states and so forth and what I
found across all this research is that
one of the biggest and most important
differences among human groups is how
tight or loose they are and that just
reflects how strict their social norms
are and how much permissive the how much
permissiveness they have for human
behavior and what's really important
about this difference is that across
time and across nations are stakes the
same factors predict why groups evolved
to have tighter norms or stricter norms
and it has a lot to do with how much
threat that they experience so when we
published a paper in science a few years
ago we showed that nations that have a
lot of threat whether it's natural
disasters or it's invasions that they've
been threatened by over a hundred years
or
even disease prevalence they tend to
have much stronger norms and it makes a
lot of sense because when you have
threat you need tight rules and strong
leaders to help you coordinate to
survive we've been showing this in
computer models that when you have
threat tightness evolves and that's a
really important evolutionary principle
and instinct that we have as human
groups so to give us a sense like where
where does the u.s. rank on this in
terms of the scale so that we kind of
understand maybe that spectrum is well
it's interesting I mean the US has in
our data been typically more loose and
years on the loose side with some
pockets of tightness in different areas
in the US you know as a nation were
separated by two oceans from other
countries we haven't been worried about
being invaded for centuries by Mexico
and Canada and so we have evolved to
have looser norms there are states that
have tighter norms typically are in the
south and the Midwest as compared to the
coast and actually in our data you could
see that natural disasters and other
threats actually predict that level of
tightness so there's a there's also some
within culture variation there's also if
you zoom into States this variation in
social class and we often think about
social classes just being about bank
accounts but actually in our research
the working class is far tighter than
the upper class they want stronger rules
they need stronger rules because they
have much more threat whether it's
falling into poverty or it's working in
dangerous occupations or being in
neighborhoods where rules really help
keep kids out of trouble okay so now
we're getting into one of the specific
elements I want to deal with and it's
sort of funny and timely that you
mentioned invasion threats from Mexico
because right now we're actually seeing
a very deliberate effort in some media
to frame the immigrant asylum seeking
Caravan as possible invaders we need to
protect ourselves they could rape women
kill kids and take our jobs store sort
of thing and what I've identified is
that it is a hugely beneficial thing for
huge corporations and for governments
that may tend to go in the authoritarian
or autocratic direction to make it so
that American workers
example blame Mexicans for as an example
for stagnant wages or job loss rather
than the status quo corporate power that
we have in the United States can you
talk a little bit about that and this
kind of class division and how it can be
used by bad actors yeah this is actually
something that's not just relevant to
today it's been happening for centuries
and like I mentioned it taps into this
very deep evolutionary principle that
when we feel threatened whether that's
real or whether it's illusory we want
tighter groups and we want strong
leaders to help us coordinate it
actually helps groups when we have real
threat to have tight rules and to have
strong leaders but in this case what we
see more and more is that we're not so
clear especially the United States um
what's real and what's illusory when it
comes to thread the working class for
example is more threatened for sure than
the upper class but and we've seen in
our studies of elections before the
Trump election people who felt more
threatened whether it's by immigrants or
Isis or North Korea wanted the country
to be tighter and that predicted their
vote for Trump that's the same dynamic
in France where we measure the same
exact variables if you perceive threat
real or imagined you want tighter norms
and stronger rulers now with that said
your your intuition is exactly on point
you sounded good cross-cultural
psychologists because leaders can
actually amplify an exaggerated threat
target people who are more threatened
and use that to gain popularity and it's
a very powerful tactic I've actually
brought people into my own lab and I've
actually manipulated fake threats like
terrorism or natural disasters or
pathogen prevalence and you could see
within moments people tighten up in the
lab they want stronger rules and I start
to become more ethnocentric and that's
exactly what leaders around the world
are doing you see it not just in the
u.s. not just in France you see it in
Italy you seen a hungry there using a
tight blues playbook actually using
terms like we have Muslim invaders or
fun with say in Hungary where our
culture is being destroyed they're
saying in Italy and these are very
strong words and they tap into this
instinct of tightness where people who
believe that will instantly support
stronger rules and stronger leaders so
you mentioned the the kind of
evolutionary angle I mean is it is we
could all imagine I guess how on on the
savanna if you believe that you are
threatened by lions for example you are
definitely going to be motivated by that
fear to a point or allow the leader to
have a particular personality and to
sort of manage the people around them in
a particular way is is how strong is
that evolutionary component to this and
then what else has culture sort of added
to it yeah so we have that a lot of
evidence for that very principle we can
measure threat actual how much threat
groups face so in the study I did across
30 plus nations we measured how many
times as a nation been potentially
invaded by its neighbors objectively how
many natural disasters has a has a
country actually had to face in terms of
mother nature's fury
or famines by the way we did this also
with traditional societies over 80
societies that exist in the ancient
archaeological record where we can
actually assess how much threat did they
have in terms of famine and in terms of
invasions and how strong are norms do
they have how tight were their norms how
much do they have autocratic leaders and
the connection is the same whether it's
modern nations or traditional societies
or the u.s. 50 states it's a very strong
connection when you have threat you need
stronger rules to survive and the
leaders that can help provide those
rules and enforce them it's just that
that principle can get hijacked by
leaders and it's happened you know not
just nowadays and I gotta mentioned
centuries it's been happening where
leaders can use that psychology in order
to win elections there are some places
I've been to like for example
Switzerland strikes me as an example
that seems to be kind of an unusual mix
in terms of this spectrum of kind of
individualism versus collectivism but
also in terms of kind of social norms I
mean I guess question one is are there
am I accurately identifying that
something's a little bit different in
Switzerland maybe on the spectrum that
you've identified and and how do we
understand places like that Austria
maybe is another example yeah I think
it's a really good question and I'll
just back up and say all cultures have
both
loose elements just we have more or less
of them and so you can zoom into the
United States and find even though it's
generally has been loose you can have C
domains that we pretty are still pretty
strict about for example privacy is
something we pretty tightly regulate in
the United States it's a really core
value or other countries that will
tightly subscribe norms around other
important values what's interesting is
in our research we really see a big
difference between tightness and things
like collectivism so collectivism is
about your connection with your family
with your in groups tightness is about
the strength of norms in the cultural
context and punishments for deviating
from norms and you can see that there
are basically collectivist cultures that
are tight they tend to be in East Asia
and individualistic cultures that tend
to be loose that's generally been the US
and Australia but there's really
interesting contrast where you have a
lot of individualism and this is some
privacy but tightness and that's Austria
Germany Switzerland and you can also
have groups that are very family
oriented very collectivistic but loose
and that in our data are for example as
Brazil and Spain so they're really
different constructs they're related but
they're really distinct and so it's
important to remember that as we kind of
try to understand other cultures that
they're not always just one dimension
that we can place them on so to circle
back to the fear element for for a
moment it does seem that fear is a very
good motivator for influencing how
people vote and the actions that people
take my analysis politically is that in
the United States there's one party that
tends to use fear much more
significantly than the other in terms of
justifying why you should vote for them
and that's the Republican Party over the
Democratic Party at an evolutionary
level like we don't even have to have a
debate about the politics of it at some
base level does that mean that Democrats
are already at a disadvantage when they
are not using fear in the same way as
Republicans I think it's a really good
question I I think my point of view is
that Democrats should be more aware of
this psychology in order to counteract
it so for example the working class is
objectively more threatened then we need
to deal with those threats those
disruptions right and I think focusing
on those issues will go a long way I
think we need to also challenge these
these stereotypes of fear we have to be
pushing back on how dangerous these
kinds of groups are and and really put
things in perspective and have more of a
dialogue about even a threat meter like
how objective you know is this real is
this threat because really another
problem that I see with this dynamic is
that tight loose has a lot of trade-offs
for groups tight groups have a lot of
order they have a lot of uniformity and
they have a lot of self control people
behaving themselves that's really
important when you have a lot of threat
but loose groups who have less threat
tends to be more creative and the more
adaptable more flexible and so that when
you get to extreme levels of tightness
especially arbitrary levels of tightness
you're losing out on creativity and
adaptability so we have to really
negotiate the level of objective threat
that we're experiencing or else we're
gonna lose off on a lot of advantages
we've had as a society which is a
tremendous amount of creativity and
flexibility when you have tightness you
tend to have order but also
ethnocentrism people who look different
who act different who seem different
seem threatening and people are very
discriminatory against them both in
nations in traditional societies and in
states we show we have evidence for this
very directly so I think that's why we
have to really try to negotiate this
fear you know the big book of the of the
fall is fear in the White House what we
really have to be talking about is fear
outside of the White House people have
to be constantly challenging the
perception that everything is a disaster
we've been speaking with Michele Gelfand
who's a distinguished University
professor at the University of Maryland
leading expert on cultural differences
her new book is called rule makers rule
breakers how tight and loose cultures
wire our world Michele thank you so much
for talking to me about this today
thanks a lot
and now please see my website and send
me some type moose stories if you have
some